[Music]
thank you
however without this honesty laws do not
have validity as the essence of
Consciousness nor similarly does the
testing of them count as an action
within consciousness
on the contrary these moments appearing
each by itself immediately as a reality
expressed in the one case an invalid
establishing and existence of actual
laws and in the other case an equally
invalid immunity from them the law as a
specific law has a contingent content
and this means here that it is the law
of a single Consciousness and has an
arbitrary content to legislate
immediately in that way is thus the
tyrannical insolence which makes Caprice
into a law and ethical Behavior into
obedience to such Caprice obedience to
laws which are merely laws and not at
the same time commandments so to the
second moment insofar as it is isolated
means testing the laws moving the
immovable means the insolence of a
knowledge which argues itself into a
freedom from absolute laws treating them
as an alien Caprice
paragraph 434 is in many respects quite
an exciting one just from the very
language that Hegel is using we have a
contrast between honesty or air leak
kite and uh sort of a basis of of
capriciousness
vilker and insolence Fable right these
are these are words that have a very
strong senses to them we have a strong
contrast here over the way in which laws
are supposed to work within and for
consciousness
um so I you know I'm just mentioning
here at the very beginning because when
you can you know read the German and you
see some of the sort of uh the just the
the language itself we don't get a lot
of places in Hegel where the the very
terminology that he's picking has these
kinds of resonances so I think we have
to to uh be attuned to that when it does
happen much of the time his prose is
more abstract and and uh he's he's not
you know uh he's not giving us that sort
of thing so we have to seize it when it
does happen
anyway uh on to the the analysis so he
says without this honesty laws do not
have a validity a gulting kite uh in two
ways
um
we have laws and we've seen these two
moments now of giving laws and testing
laws right giving laws he says here is
the essence of What Not all
Consciousness necessarily although law
giving does play an important role at
many points think about forcing the
understanding but here he's talking
about ethical Consciousness or practical
Consciousness giving laws really is at
the core of this Hegel thanks
um in that he is really in agreement
with many people throughout the history
of philosophy you might you might think
first of all about his predecessor Kant
but um it's not as if Kant is the only
person who thinks that laws are really
Central really at the core of practical
activity
um the notion of natural law that we
find in a very dim way in Aristotle and
somewhat stronger in the stoics and then
you know worked out very clearly by
Thomas Aquinas and then you know worked
on further by his predecessor by his his
uh uh successors not predecessors uh
they're obviously not going to be
reading him if they're his predecessors
um we we find that uh sort of
universalization as well
um and we can we can find many other
examples of this this is really core to
what it means to be a human being this
is not just in Western culture but also
this this process of universalization we
see this in other cultures that engage
in moral decision making discussion and
disagreement
so giving laws is at the essence of
Consciousness and then testing laws
Hegel says here is the action within
ethical or practical self-consciousness
these two go together as we've seen as
Hegel just remarked several paragraphs
before this if we isolate them from each
other uh we find that they they don't
have validity gulty kites worthwhileness
you might say but when we put them
together and we do so under the auspices
of this this honesty this early kite you
know if you think about what what this
this honesty means it's not just about
truth telling it's about
um honoring
you know giving era to what deserves
honor giving uh giving you know when we
talk about respecting something right
that is
I think along the lines of what Hegel is
is calling early kite here
so Hegel suggests that
um this is early kite this honesty
uh is is needed there for laws to have
validity uh in consciousness
now he says on the contrary these
moments appearing each by itself
immediately as a reality
uh isolated again again out from from
their their connection Express in the
one case an invalid establishing an
existence of actual laws in the other
case an equally invalid immunity from
them so when we when we break them apart
um and we we don't find some way to
integrate them
what we get is
um in some respects something like the
inverted world of of the force from the
and and and uh yeah the the law-giving
nature the world creating nature of
force in the understanding section
so what does he mean here let's look at
the actual terminology here
invalid establishing Australian and
existence Zine of these laws this
corresponds to the giving laws
which is supposed to be at the essence
of Consciousness so it's possible for us
to erect Australian to to set in place
laws uh that are themselves invalid or
we do so in an invalid way
um we're going to see how that plays
itself out in just a moment and their
very existence they're very being could
be in some respect wrong
right
testing laws the action within
consciousness
corresponding to this we can have an
invalid immunity as as Miller's
translating it uh we might also use the
term uh exceptioning right the frion
freeing oneself of these these laws
saying well they don't apply to me or I
get to adapt them to my particular
circumstances the honest Consciousness
is honest because there's universality
there here we have and this is where
Hegel uses these wonderful terms right
Caprice vilker and insolence
audacity would be another way of
translating it
um when we say I don't believe
you have the guts to do that
we're talking about Fable there right
I'm going to say vilker could it could
be Caprice it could be arbitrariness we
can think of other ways of rendering
this as well but Hegel uh uses these
terms to talk about a subjective
Consciousness that is becoming you know
subjective against the universal it's
not that subjectivity is bad as a matter
of fact we have to have subjectivity
right we can never escape from it but
there's good subjectivity and bad
subjectivity this is bad subjectivity
when it comes to laws and it invalidates
them as laws
so he says here
the law as a specific law
has a contingent con content this means
here that is the law of a single
Consciousness and has an arbitrary a
vilker content
where have we seen this play itself out
before
think back to just a few sections
earlier in this massive reason section
to the law of the heart and the dynamic
that played itself out there
the law of the heart was a law for that
individual self-consciousness but then
it attempts to impose that on others
right so we have
an invalid establishing or erecting or
imposing of the law so Hegel goes on and
says to legislate immediately in that
way is thus the tyrannical insolence
which makes Caprice into a law and
ethical Behavior into obedience to such
Caprice
that's a problem you know it's possible
to impose
laws not just by force not just by going
up to people and saying look do what I
say or I'm going to kill you or I'm
going to punch you or it'd be a terrible
thing of your story here burden down uh
or I'm going to hurt your family or I'm
going to impose Financial penalties on
you or you know we're gonna use social
pressure all those sorts of things
that's that's one aspect of it but
there's another aspect where you have a
a you know arbitrary Authority that's
acting in a tyrannical way
and it's relying on the fact that there
are honest consciousnesses out there who
will receive the arbitrarily given law
and say well I mean it is the rules I
have to follow it what would happen if I
didn't do that we see this Dynamic over
and over and over again not just in
terms of political communities
but also in terms of family Dynamics we
also see this in the workplace we see
this in Academia and our uh universities
and colleges we see this in so many
different ways where some sort of uh
Authority gives us a rule a law a norm
and uh you know people say well I do
have to follow it but what does this
mean Hegel spells it out ethical
Behavior becomes obedience to Caprice
obedience to arbitrariness
there's something fundamentally
I don't want to say irrational
but corrupting and damaging to
rationality
damaging to honesty involved in that
Hegel goes on
he says um
obedience to laws which are merely laws
and not at the same time Commandments
there's a distinction between
laws or rules or regulations as given by
a substantively rational agent
and those that are given by an agent who
is acting in a capricious arbitrary
tyrannical
insolent way
seeing what they can get away with
that's on one side now on the other side
we have this you know freeing oneself
immunity or exceptioning oneself from
the law he says the second moment
insofar as it is isolated means testing
the laws moving the immovable
uh means the insolence of a knowledge
which argues itself into a freedom from
absolute laws treating them is an alien
Caprice this is particularly interesting
and something that we get to see quite
often could be that the laws actually
aren't capricious and are given by
Honest Consciousness legislating for for
the whole
but this this action of testing laws
itself can become corrupted itself can
become you know uh we let's call it
filled with a spirit of capriciousness
of me first I I I get to decide
and insolence
uh you're not going to tell me what to
do
it's quite possible
to behave in a way that seems on the
surface critical
rational
but really is just reflective of One's
Own desire to call the shots and to not
have other people imposing Norms upon
you
and if those really are valid norms and
you do that you're setting yourself at
odds not just with other people but with
something inherent to the very nature of
rational self-consciousness
this is equally deforming
but deforming in a different way it it
raises an interesting question which
Hegel doesn't go into here if you have
capricious laws being imposed by a
tyrannical Authority and you also have
somebody who you know for from their own
egoism is critiquing and accepting
themselves from those laws which one is
worse and is it good for this one to be
doing that uh you know because they are
removing themselves from an illegitimate
law
interesting conundrum isn't it not one
that Hegel explores here but it is one
that I think could be raised at this
point what Hegel is Keen to show us here
is the contrast between two forms of
Consciousness in relation to laws
in both forms these moments are a
negative relation to substance or real
spiritual being or we may say that in
them substance does not as yet possess
its reality but rather that
Consciousness contains them still in the
form of its own immediacy and that
substance is at first only a willing and
knowing by this particular individual or
the ought to be of an unreal commandment
and a knowledge of formal universality
but since these modes have been
superseded Consciousness has returned
into the universal and those antitheses
have vanished spiritual being is the
actual substance through these modes
being valid not in isolation but only as
superseded moments and the unity in
which they are merely moments is the
self of Consciousness which being from
now on posited in the spiritual being
makes that being actual fulfilled and
self-conscious
in paragraph 435 Hegel is now beginning
to bring matters to a head and tie them
all together preparing us for moving
into the next Main and massive section
you notice that he's already using here
a term that is going to be the Hallmark
of the next section
geistiga spiritual
um and and we're trying to figure out
what what Spirit actually is
well-being parts of it and participating
in it so he says in both forms what are
the both forms the two kinds of
consciousnesses that we just looked at
in the previous passage the one that is
arbitrary the one that is honest these
moments are a negative relation to
substance or to real spiritual being so
we start off by talking about real
spiritual being used with the term real
there geistiga these and and we could
translate that as Essence if we wanted
being perhaps works well here at this
point
and he says or we may say in them that
substance does not as yet possess its
reality but that Consciousness contains
them still in the form of its own
immediacy immediacy meaning it has not
figured out all the mediations all the
connections it has not worked through
them but by the end of this it will have
worked through a good portion of them
so he says at Fir and that that
substance is at first only a willing and
knowing by this particular individual
right or the ought to be of an unreal
commandment and knowledge of formal
universality
so
what we've got here is a kind of
antithesis right
um
we also have the antithesis over here
well I don't know if we want to call it
an antithesis as such Hegel does talk in
the plural of antitheses we have the law
giving and the law testing that we've
seen can't be dealt with adequately as
isolated moments but over here what
we're really focused on is this
antithesis between the willing or
knowing by the particular individual
knowing what knowing
moral Norms knowing the situation in
which they have to act willing choosing
something
and then what Hegel calls an unreal
commandment uh and a knowledge of formal
universality well that's the stuff that
we've been talking about in the previous
paragraphs knowledge of formal
universality knowing that something does
not contain a contradiction in itself in
its its sort of undeveloped notion in
its its simple determinateness although
it turns out that it always does have
some sort of contradiction once we start
spilling playing it out like you know
with property or benevolence so he goes
out and he says
um since these modes have been
superseded and there is a little bit of
a
mistranslation in in part because it
makes it a bit passive
um Hegel uses the term the verb auf
Haven there right and he's he's using it
talking about these modes
performing auf Haven on themselves they
they are superseding themselves leading
to this right so the alphaben is
happening within consciousness of these
moments that now have revealed
themselves to be just parts of a larger
whole things that need to be
reintegrated with each other modes is a
translation of Vise in here ways would
be another way of translating it so he
says since these modes have been
superseded Consciousness has returned
into the universal and those antitheses
have vanished
spiritual being right real spiritual
being is what apps actual substance
vehicle substance
through these modes being valid not in
isolation right law giving law testing
the individual the universal these are
not valid isolated out from each other
but only in their interconnection in
Consciousness in the real spiritual
being so what does that mean that means
that the actual substance that is the
real spiritual being is also going to be
what Hagel calls here the self of
consciousness
right
um their superseded moments these things
uh and the unity in which they are
merely moments
is the self of consciousness
us our self our thinking
which being from now on positive he says
in the spiritual being makes that being
notice
Consciousness being in the spiritual
being makes that actual Veer Clique
fulfilled
and
self-conscious so it's not as if the
spiritual being is there and it's just
sort of like waiting for us to get the
message and get our
self-consciousnesses into it no this is
something that is a hard one uh spoil of
victory of self-consciousness trying to
think through all of these things having
to do with normativity and you know the
universality of laws law giving and law
testing
the spiritual being thus exists first of
all for self-consciousness as law which
has an intrinsic being the universality
associated with testing the law a merely
formal not an essential universality is
now behind us the law is equally an
eternal law which is grounded not in the
will of a particular Universal but is
valid in and for itself it is the
absolute pure will of all which has the
form of immediate being also it is not a
commandment which only ought to be it is
and is valid it is the universal eye of
the category the I which is immediately
a reality and the world is only this
reality
but since this existent law is valid
unconditionally The Obedience of
self-consciousness is not the serving of
a master whose commands are arbitrary
and in which it would not recognize
itself on the contrary laws are the
thoughts of its own absolute
Consciousness thoughts which are
immediately its own also it does not
believe in them for though although
belief does perceive essential being it
perceives it as something alien to
itself ethical self-consciousness is
immediately one with essential being
through the universality of itself
belief on the other hand starts from the
individual Consciousness it is the
movement of that Consciousness always
towards this Unity but without attaining
to the presence of its essential being
the above Consciousness on the other
hand is put has put its merely
individual aspect behind it this
mediation is finished and complete and
only because this is so is this
Consciousness immediate
self-consciousness of the ethical
substance
okay
in paragraph 436 we are now almost on
the cusp not only of finishing this this
pretty short section of reason as
testing laws or the larger section of
individuality real in and for itself but
the massive reason section itself we are
just one other paragraph away from
making the transition between the two
largest portions of this this entire
work and what's happening here in this
paragraph is again what was what I
talked about in the previous one a
consolidation
and a realization we're seeing auf
habong sublation essential hegelian
concept at work right now
um what do we have Hegel 2x now about
the the spiritual being existing first
of all for self-conscious us as law
which has an intrinsic being
no longer laws as they weren't there
before and now they're given or laws
that were testing all of that is to a
certain extent behind us not completely
but but at this point at least law that
has an intrinsic being
the universality associated with testing
the law a merely formal not an essential
universality now behind us right we're
no longer to make appeals to these
criteria of tautology or a lack of
self-contradiction we're going to get
into something more substantive
now here's where he says something
really interesting the law is equally an
eternal law avias
Eternal this has some major resonances
going far back into the history of
philosophy
who talks about eternal law well you
might you know if you're if you're
inclined towards medieval philosophy
think in terms of Thomas Aquinas well
you should also think in terms of
Augustine you should think in terms of
all these thinkers who thought there was
some sort of intelligible normativity
that that encompassed everything
Hegel is using that language quite
deliberately a universal law
or Eternal law rather it is universal of
course but it's Eternal what does he say
about this
it's grounded not in the will of a
particular individual
but valid in and for itself it doesn't
have its grund its foundation in a
particular individual the particular
individual you could say is preceded by
this this eternal law
and finds itself within the scope of of
that Eternal law
so he says it is the absolute pure will
of all
that's another key feature of this the
absolute pure will
of all
so this keeps it from being just well
it's the Eternal law the way that say
Thomas Aquinas conceived of it God's
mind God's law uh and then everything
else sort of falls into place within it
no this is this is going to be an
important transformative moment and he's
not working further the implications of
this out right now but we are going to
see this in this the the spirit and the
religion section and especially in
absolute knowing
and it has the form notice what he says
here of immediate being when mithilbaris
zein
so again we have immediacy here looks
like some pretty good immediacy but
immediacy is always a sign that there's
more more yet to come for Hegel
so what else does he say about this he
says also it's not a commandment which
only ought to be the normativity that it
has is not a shadowy
quasi-normativity it is a saturated
overloading things normativity it is the
universal eye of the category the I
which is immediately a reality and the
world is only this reality
why does he say the world is only this
reality
think back to the very beginning of the
reason section what was it that rational
self-consciousness began with as its
Hallmark it is the world it is the world
is for it
right so now we have it in terms of this
this Universal eye
now how does this fit in with you and me
people
individual self-consciousnesses so
census existent law is valid
unconditionally The Obedience of
self-consciousness is not the serving of
a master whose commands are arbitrary
and in which it would not recognize
itself so we already have two important
moments here there's obedience on the
part of the self-consciousness there is
recognition what does it recognize
he says it uh it here we go
um it recognizes itself
the laws are the thoughts of its own
absolute Consciousness thoughts which
are immediately its own we are not just
little bits and pieces of this eternal
law as Consciousness we're able to grasp
it as us being part of that all in the
pure will of all
so he goes on and he says
these are thoughts where which are
immediately its own now notice the next
thing he says it does not believe in
them
right
um it doesn't it doesn't have faith you
might say in them the same term belief
Faith glauba right
um
why not
although belief does perceive essential
being it perceives it as something alien
to itself where have we seen this come
up
think back to the unhappy Consciousness
right this is not
repeating the unhappy Consciousness
there's something different going on
here
ethical self-consciousness he says is
immediately one with essential being
through the universality of itself so
insofar as there's something Universal
within us we are able to participate in
this we are able to recognize that we're
able to obey it we don't need to believe
in it we can be it
belief on the other hand starts from the
individual Consciousness it is the
movement of that Consciousness always
towards that Unity but without attaining
to the presence of its essential being
now eagle goes on he says the above
Consciousness has put its merely
individual aspect behind it this
mediation is finished and complete only
because this is so is this Consciousness
immediate self-consciousness of the
ethical substance
so if you can get yourself to that point
that sounds pretty awesome doesn't it
sounds like we finally attained the uh
matter in hand or core of the matter the
project the zakazelps that we're seeking
we finally reconciled uh the ethical
substance that we had originally in the
community with something that's now
revealed as going Way Beyond any
individual Community or any individual
person and it's just up to us to do what
identify with it obey it recognize it
that's part of what still has to be
worked out remember this is still
hegel's using the term here immediate
and so we're going to see further
development taking place after this much
of which is going to happen in the
spirit section